solo les hago saber a todas que son
hermosas sí lo sabemos está bien solo me
aseguro pero tengo que ser brutalmente
honesto de algún modo
Si tuvieras que clasificarte frente a
otros en función de un rasgo específico
que diría eso sobre cómo se los ves y
cómo te ven ellos a ti reunimos a cinco
parejas y las novias se clasificaron
según lo atractivas que creían que eran
luego invitamos a sus novios a
reorganizarlas esto es la clasificación
Hola Mi nombre es a yanía Tengo 23 años
y soy una coache emocional de Sacramento
Hola a todos Soy Vera Tengo 23 años y
soy estudiante de doctorado vaya ya
ganaste
soy Sofía tengo 19 y soy estudiante
Universitaria
soy Jennifer tengo 26 años y soy
administradora de propiedades y también
soy una prometedora gente de bienes
raíces
soy Sky tengo 21 soy estudiante y
también estoy obteniendo mi
certificación de pilates
yo definiría el atractivo como algo que
hace que tu cuerpo se sienta como la
persona te atrae o más bien vpl si
tienes una gran personalidad eres
divertida enérgica tener algún tipo de
propósito creo que es más que
físicalidad pienso en Cómo se comportan
si cuidan de sí mismos la higiene como
huelen y la higiene es importante
mi novio me conoció en la universidad y
siempre cuenta Esta historia sobre cómo
me vio en la biblioteca y dijo Adiós
miren a ese bombón Que obviamente lo
estoy siempre ha sido un poco tímido por
lo que nunca se acercó a mí ni nada así
que nos conocimos oficialmente en tinder
Así que sí En definitiva creo que piensa
que soy atractiva O al menos eso espero
mi novio me contactó en sus palabras
metiéndose en mis mensajes directos es
lo que dijo Creo que piensa que soy
atractiva Él es quien hizo el primer
movimiento Así que vamos a decir que sí
éramos compañeros de trabajo en la
barbería Y obviamente yo era la más
bonita en mi trabajo
Bueno nos conocimos por primera vez en
tinder le gustaría mucho así que sumo
que se siente atraído aquí estamos ahora
cinco años y medio después
nos conocimos en la secundaria me elogió
por mis zapatos me dijo Me gustan tus
zapatos yo estaba como lo sé pero lo
puse en la friendzone primero Así que
nos tomó un tiempo llegar hasta aquí
pero ya llevamos un año y medio juntos
[Risas]
Yo creo que todas aquí son
definitivamente Muy atractivo creo que
todas somos muy seguras de quienes somos
y eso ya es atractivo en sí mismo
bien bien
primero que nada ninguna son cinco creo
que todas somos muy atractivas y
deberíamos empezar con los atuendos me
gusta su atuendo
muy lindo así
debes venir aquí
Ven conmigo sí es cierto Me pareces a
Olivia Rodrigo
está bien y tus uñas también
la atención al detalle como las cuentas
el collar los Anillos tal vez tatuajes
porque he visto que tienen algunos
tatuajes
[Risas]
creo que tengo muchos tatuajes estúpidos
tengo una integración matemática en mi
espalda Es muy Nerf creo que deberías
estar aquí siento que eres como la
señorita es talión tu cabello tus
estudios
haces deportes porque sí eres atlética
eso es atractivo también
casi fui a los Juegos Olímpicos tanto de
patinaje sobre hielo como de esquí voy
al gimnasio por Claridad mental y solo
para mejorar mi apariencia física bien
Sí eso es muy bueno porque los gimnasios
me asustan hombres
personalidad por personalidad me iría
contigo
Eres todo un personaje en el buen
sentido tú también sube definitivamente
soy más callada y mira yo también soy
así sin duda Yo solo hablo mucho no te
confundas tienes una sonrisa muy bonita
soy como una quemadura
sus piernas estás bromeando yo estoy
construida como un corgi ven
bien yo también no no no no amiga
Quédate ahí genial ahora tomen una
combinación promedio entre personalidad
y apariencia general para que sea esa su
clasificación final Definitivamente
creo que está bien como tercera sí
me esperaba ser la número 5 No porque no
tenga una buena opinión de mí misma sino
porque estaba en un no sé con todas esas
hermosas mujeres y a todas ellas les
está pasando algo en sus vidas también
Siento que estoy bien en donde me
colocaron
No lo sé tengo una idea tomémonos de la
mano y así seremos todas número uno muy
bien tiene sentido se entiende el
mensaje abrimos conectadas
[Música]
de menos a más diría en menos
diría la del cuello alto solo porque no
es mi estilo dos ella porque no me
gustan las chicas altas eso están
[Risas]
tres cuatro
cinco creo que iré con cinco la de los
calcetines azules solo porque ella salta
y Yo mido como unos 70 haré cuatro tres
dos uno
comenzaré desde la 1 yo diría uno sí dos
dos me gusta lo de los pilates creo que
es muy genial 3 está haciendo un
doctorado lo cual es realmente genial 4
creo que es súper dulce y luego cinco
nada en contra Simplemente no es mi tipo
Pero sigue siendo genial tiene una gran
personalidad comenzaré desde las 5 creo
que ella es genial tiene una gran
personalidad o simplemente no es algo
que encuentre tan atractivo en
particular cuatro tiene un cuello de
tortuga muy lindo y es muy dulce tres y
luego dos tiene una especie de vibra
Kardashian eso fue lo que eso y luego la
uno obviamente mi novia diría que la
número 5 sería ella no es mi tipo Aunque
me encanta su cabello número 4 diría que
es ella está más del lado tranquilo
número 3 diría que ella porque es un
poco demasiado alta para mí diría yo tal
vez mucho más hasta que yo me encanta su
Estilo me encanta la chaqueta larga y
por supuesto la número Dónde estaba Son
5 número 5 Claro
porque es mi novia sino porque me
encanta lo simple y eso es lo que me
hizo sí elegirla
[Música]
solo les hago saber a todas que son
hermosas así lo sabemos bien un solo me
aseguro pero tengo que ser brutalmente
honesto de algún modo
[Música]
[Aplausos]
la número 1 ella sería esa persona a la
que acudiría si necesitara apoyo amor y
me gusta la sencillez número 2 me
encanta tu atuendo número 3 calcetines
geniales número 4 ella también es genial
y número 5 muy bien también Simplemente
no es mi tipo pero no hay resentimientos
verdad
número 1 tenemos una conexión muy
especial probablemente una de las
personas más bellas cariñosas y
asombrosas
dos creo que tiene un aspecto genial de
Kardashian un tres también atractiva
pero un poco en el extremo tímido 4
parece una persona muy cariñosa y 5 no
Exactamente mi estilo pero también tiene
una gran personalidad en primer lugar la
adoro absolutamente y creo que es la
chica más hermosa del mundo y es la
persona de pensamiento más libre que he
conocido en mi vida y luego dos parece
muy madura para su edad tres ella
también es muy inteligente y cuatro ella
es súper dulce sabe cuál es su lugar y
quién es tiene mucha confianza cinco
también diría que no es necesariamente
emititivo pero me encanta la confianza y
me encanta como es ella Ella es mi
número uno no se necesita explicar uno
es uno la mejor
número 2 se parece Olivia Rodrigo
puse la número 3 porque su personalidad
es genial es muy relajada buena vibra la
número 4 solo porque es simple y me
gusta su trabajo y todo eso y luego la
número 5 la puse de última porque no es
mi tipo pero ella es muy inteligente es
genial
primera Estoy siendo parcial pero esta
mujer Es súper divina y merece todo mi
tiempo dos me gusta su atuendo y su
cabello 3 más o menos lo mismo 4 Esta
persona es atlética y motivada y luego
cinco no hay razón específica Solo que
alguien debe ser la última
Puedes cambiar con Jennifer
Jennifer Puedes cambiar con Vera
[Música]
Puedes cambiar con Sofía
y luego Sofía Puedes cambiar con Skype
y esta fue la clasificación promedio
[Risas]
parece la elección de un chico
siento que no deberías estar de última
La Última colocación me tomó por
sorpresa así
No creo que debe estar aquí
te sorprendió
un poco sí no estoy muy segura de lo que
los chicos tomaron en cuenta pero creo
que las chicas tienen una perspectiva
más sincera
yo estando en el medio también tiene
sentido porque también estoy un poco más
en el atractivo estereotípico tengo el
cabello rubio soy alta un poco de todas
estas cosas que creces escuchando que
son atractivas claro
[Música]
número cinco No creo que la
clasificación se base ni siquiera en el
atractivo creo que acabamos de ponernos
en nuestros lugares no me estoy tomando
nada personalmente sí Sigo pensando que
soy linda no soy tan atractiva Pero sigo
pensando que soy una bonita chica ganas
algo pierdes algo no todos Pensarán que
eres un bombón